thank you Bill when I noticed that I was
the last scheduled research speaker I
was certain since we were going to run
late that I would be out of time or I'd
only be given a minute or two but I
noticed where we're about 10 minutes
ahead of schedule so I get 10 min okay
thank you and and and and and thanks
thanks to our very strict master
ceremonies here and also to the
disciplined speakers who preceded me my
research focus is on government policy
I've I've worked in the past mostly with
agricultural economists on agricultural
trade policy on farm subsidy policies on
agricultural development policy
particularly in Africa and on policies
toward agricultural technology including
including biotechnology but my my newest
published work is on obesity policies
comparing obesity policies in the United
States to policies in Europe and Japan
in particular this book from Oxford
University Press is going to come out
next month the the the somewhat tabloid
title and the lurid jacket art that was
Oxford University Press Believe It or
Not who insisted upon that the the
purpose of this book is to explain why
the United States is such an outlier
among other advanced industrial
countries both in the prevalence of
obesity obesity prevalence in the United
States is twice as high as it is in
Europe and also in per-capita
consumption of fossil fuels co2
emissions per capita in the United
States are also twice as high as in
Europe so this is a book about climate
change as well as obesity that's why
that's why they inserted the two tires
in there to suggest that we drive too
much as well as as eat too much my
explanation for Amer
cos XS in in these two areas is not
going to be fully satisfying to those on
the political left because I'm saying
it's not just corporate greed my
explanation is also not going to be
fully satisfying to those on the
political right because I'm saying it's
not just a decline in personal
responsibility I identify the deep
foundation of America's distinctive
tendency to over consume both both food
and fuel I find these deep foundations
in Geographic and demographic and
geologic differences between the United
States and the rest of the industrial
world also the distinctiveness of our of
our unique and easily paralyzed
political institutions and and also our
distinct culture our highly
individualistic culture leaves us more
prone than in other societies to
over-consume both both food and fuel in
fact I find America's unique
overconsumption of food and fuel to be
so over determined that it's unlikely to
be significantly corrected and this
leads me to a pessimistic conclusion as
as America keeps failing to set in place
the policies that might be needed to
mitigate obesity like taxes on soda
consumption we don't have any of the
federal level restrictions on
advertising food to children we don't
have any restrictions on what kinds of
foods can be purchased with food stamp
benefits we don't have any a restoration
of mandatory physical education in
public high schools we we haven't done
that as we continue to to fail in doing
the things that might help mitigate the
obesity problem our political leaders
may tacitly give up on mitigation and
pivot toward a posture of adaptation
toward obesity and this will include
doing a number of good things
including more public support for
medical treatment and for surgeries for
those whose health has been placed at
risk because they've become obese
it will mean larger investments in
physical accommodations for the obese
and it will mean stronger legal
protections against for example
workplace discrimination for for the
obese these are all good things but I
describe this adaptation posture as a
distant second best to effective
mitigation because it's unlikely to work
well for those segments of the American
population that are most likely to
become obese namely those with low
education those with low income
disadvantaged racial minorities these
portions the population have much more
trouble gaining access to medical
treatments to the assistance that they
will need to to live with the condition
so in a sense America's unresolved
obesity a crisis is going to be in the
end just one more component of our
larger unresolved problem with with
inequality but in in the few minutes
that I have left I'd like to cram in a
preview of my next research project
which will consider two alternative
regulatory futures for livestock and
fish production in developing countries
and we know that meat and fish
consumption in developing countries is
going to increase rapidly in the next
three or four decades this data is from
the International Food Policy Research
Institute using population and income
growth projections to project nearly a
doubling of total meat consumption in
the developing countries in in the years
ahead out to 2050 compared to 2002 this
is this is meat dairy and eggs also up
and fish production also this is
global fish production from 1950 out to
2011 you can see the steady increase but
notice that the wild fish catch hasn't
really been increasing for 15 years and
the increase now is being provisioned by
fish farming and this is particularly
growing in in Asia you can see the share
of the farmed fish population that's in
Asia Asia invented fish farming the
Chinese invented fish farming with carp
in the fifth century BC and to the
present day 60% of all aquaculture is
located in in China but globally the
fish farming industry is now significant
in fact in 2010 the total quantity of
farmed fish exceeded of the total
quantity of beef produced globally but
what we don't know yet is how this
rapidly growing livestock industry and
fish farm industry in the developing
world is going to be regulated we we do
know that that these industries will be
highly capitalized highly specialized
industrial scale activities these are
the facilities that are being built
right now but we don't know if they'll
follow what I would call the American
model of regulation or or the European
model of regulation in the United States
our regulatory system actually does a
pretty good job of ensuring that meat is
safe for consumers to eat but it does a
poor job of protecting the environment
air quality and water quality from
untreated or mismanaged animal waste in
the concentrated animal feeding
operations that now dominate the
industry it also does a poor job of
protecting human health from antibiotic
resistance risks in the United States
80% of all antibiotic use takes place in
the livestock industry not to protect
the health of the animals but to
accelerate growth and the American model
also uses extreme animal confinement in
order to reduce labor costs reduce feed
costs but with little regard for humane
treatment of the animals the European
model very quickly is is quite different
the European model in part because
Europe is so much more densely populated
four times as densely populated as the
United States Environmental Protection
is much stronger antibiotic use for
weight gain has been banned since 1998
and extreme confinement in Sall
gestation crates or battery cages for
egg-laying hens has been has been
outlawed so the question is which way
will the developing countries go if if
Vietnam is any indication Vietnam is now
the fifth largest pork producing country
on the globe they'll be following the
American model rather than the European
model which I think will bring costs but
this is a question I'd like to ask it's
a hypothesis I'd like to test in my next
project thank you very much